[Music]  that's your little girl why you seen her  missing link tattoo dad  your fucked-up daughter well where the  hell are you gonna healthy gentleman  wants that tool yeah come back tomorrow  what if I wanted her name Gideon why  don't you all [ __ ] off I'll do [ __ ] it  turn your back on the wood I'm gonna get  blamed for this breaking parole  Cameron hang on for those who don't know  me my name's John Lee  I'm a real success story  [Applause]  [Music]  I don't have to take you down with me  about all I know is running surviving  waiting there for you baby there's  nothing I can even say  I'm sorry  young that shot there see slider there's  some coke with UF first lighter ever  blend lighter Dube is possessing from  AXA uncie